[Applause]
good morning
it's great
to be in the liberal democrat seat of
tibetan and honniton
[Applause]
and i'd like to start
by congratulating devon's newest mp
richard ford
richard served our country as an officer
in the british army for 10 years
and i know richard will serve the people
of devon in parliament with the same
devotion and distinction
today the people of tiverton honeton
have spoken for the british people
and they've sent a loud and clear
message
it's time to show boris the door
[Applause]
over the past year
the liberal democrats have been beating
the conservatives across the country in
their former heartlands
and the conservative excuses for their
defeats are beginning to wear thin
liberal democrats beat them a year ago
in cheshire and amisham and they
dismissed that
as just a local matter
six months ago
liberal democrats beat them in north
shropshire
and their excuse was
they chosen the wrong candidate
when liberal democrats beat them across
the country last month
in cumbria
in somerset in wimbledon in woking
they took
they chalked it up as just mid-term
blues
it's what the spinners in number 10 call
expectations management
but i can tell number 10
the british people
are fed up and tired of having their
expectations managed
for years
boris johnson has said things will get
better
but under boris johnson's leadership
things keep getting worse
so let me tell the prime minister what
the british people expect
they expect to be led and to be led with
decency
[Applause]
and under boris johnson there is no
leadership and there is no decency
we have the worst inflation for decades
we are seeing our living standards fall
and drop
by the fastest amount since the 1950s
people can't afford to fill up their
cars
families can't afford to put food on the
table
pensioners who've worked all their lives
for their retirement
are seeing their savings disappear
before their eyes
boris johnson
has deceived the british people and
taken them for granted for far too long
he's lost the confidence of his own
party he has lost the confidence of the
people of tifton and honeton a seat
they've held
for over a hundred years
and boris johnson has lost the
confidence of the british people
boris johnson has got to go
[Applause]
but until the next election
the only people who can show
boris johnson the door
are conservative mps
so i want to manage the expectations
of conservative mps
if you fail to get rid of this
law-breaking prime
minister if your party keeps putting up
taxes
and failing to help people
if you continue to allow boris johnson
to drift with no plan for our country
the liberal democrats are coming after
you seat by seat
liberal democrats will assemble an army
of activists
we will offer the change people want
we will offer the change our country
needs
and we will drive you conservatives out
of power
[Applause]
so for all of you
who are struggling
just to make ends meet who are making
difficult choices today
just to get by
who fear what the next day's bills might
bring
let me say this
i know it might not always feel like
this
but there can be a better tomorrow
the people of tiverton and honeton have
shown that change can happen
we can build a country where you get a
fair deal
a country
where people who've worked all their
lives
can be looked after and cared for in
their old age
a country where people are free from the
fear of higher bills and higher taxes
a country where our leaders stand for
what is right and what is decent
today
the liberal democrats have shown that
the rule of boris johnson and this
uncaring conservative government can be
ended
but today
is just a start
so join us
and let's get rid of them thank you very
much
thank you very much